what's up party people
the cast of glee virtually reunited last
night at the 2021 glad media awards
to honor the legacy of the late nya
rivera and her character
santana lopez this year has been hard
and challenging in so many ways
demi lovato who played santana's
girlfriend danny on the series
kicked things off by reflecting on
santana's groundbreaking role
[Music]
the character naya played santana lopez
was groundbreaking for closeted queer
girls
like i was at the time and her ambition
and accomplishments
inspired latino women all over the world
and
neesee nash who hosted the award show
this year told et how nia's tribute has
pushed her even more to amplify voices
in the lgbtq plus community
you know what i i i just i wake up in
the morning
and i how can i be used today i love it
in that space and in that place wherever
god takes me
or wherever he places me i'm happy to
show up and do my part
aside from her powerful role in the
community jane lynch reflected on naya's
talent on the show
i remember when naya became a regular
cast member she was a dancer and i
always thought she was cute and she was
a great dancer
and then brian started giving her lines
and i was like wow
this girl is really something
[Music]
and another thing the glee cast can all
agree on is that naya's best role was
being a mom to her five-year-old son
josie
who she shared with ryan dorsey nya and
i were good friends on the show
but i think we became much better
friends when we both had children
and to see her put all that energy into
her son was just an incredible sight to
see and something i'll always remember
this july will be a year since nya's
death a source tells e.t that ryan and
nia's family
continue to do the heavy lifting when it
comes to raising josie
especially her sister nakayla rivera a
source tells e.t that josie is doing
well
quote he's the sweetest happiest little
boy and there is no shortage of love in
his life
in 2016 naya told et the greatest part
about being a mom to josie
just everything i mean absolutely
everything you know
it's very early mornings but i am so
excited
every morning it's like christmas i like
get up like 10 minutes earlier to like
go wake him up and he always greets me
with a smile
and it's just so amazing to see
unconditional love right
absolutely and and it'll never matter to
me what he does
or doesn't do